they say it's impregnable
give me 10 good men and some climbing
spikes I'll impregnate the [ __ ]
thank you
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video I want to
continue doing my character breakdown so
today I figured I would do everyone's
favorite cell sword which is Sir Bronn
of the Blackwater I will be giving my
thoughts on how I think bronze story
will end there were a few different
things that happened in the season 7
finale that gave me a hint as to what
Bronn will do next but first I want to
go over bronze current situation ever
since Tyrion was arrested for Joffrey's
murder bran has switched his allegiance
to his brother Jaime now don't get me
wrong
Bronn still has love for Tyrion and I
don't think he would ever hurt him but
Jaime is the one who is currently paying
him and Jaime still owes him a lot
Jaime has been promising Bronn a big
castle ever since season 5 when he had
brought accompany him to Dorne to rescue
his daughter Marcella
Jaime did give Bronn some gold from the
Tyrells to hold him over but he still
owes him a castle and we all know a
Lannister always pays his debts you
promised me a lordship and a castle and
a highborn beauty for the wife and
you'll get all three a Lannister all
groan say it [ __ ] say the only
problem is Jaime really isn't in any
position to just hand over a castle to
Bronn now that Jaime has left Cersei she
isn't about to sit back and allow Jaime
to give away any of the lands or castles
they currently possess Jaime isn't going
to be given Bronn Casterly Rock
that's his family's ancestral home Jaime
isn't gonna be giving bra and Riverrun
either because I don't think the Starks
would ever allow that to happen
Bronn wouldn't be able to hold a castle
for long just like with Highgarden bran
could have taken that castle but
Daenerys was on her way to take it back
some people have said bran could end up
getting the twins but I want to talk
about that later I think in order for
Jaime to have control over anything he's
gonna need to dispose of Cersei first
but it appears that Jaime isn't planning
on doing that just yet the last time we
saw Jaime he was leaving King's Landing
and most likely heading north so he can
keep his word by helping Jon and
Daenerys defeat the night king when bran
finds out Jaime
the city he will need to make a decision
about what he will do next he could
leave King's Landing or even Westeros
and go try and live the rest of his life
quietly or he can find Jaime and stay by
his side until he gets what is owed bran
could go north with Jaime and help him
defeat the army of the dead then they
can deal with Cersei later but there is
another option bran could always team up
with Tyrion again bran and Tyrion
reunited right outside the dragon pit in
Tyrion told him his offer still stands
don't you worry about me I'm doing all
right looking after myself are you
helping me to arrange this meeting
wasn't exactly after yourself was it
Tyrion offered to double bronze pay but
at the time bran was still comfortable
with his current position with Jaime
now that Jaime has left the city broad
may want to reconsider that offer and
I'm pretty confident we will see bran
again and I'm pretty confident he will
go north
Cersei could definitely pay bran to stay
with her but given their contracts I
just don't see that happening
there is a reason brought in Cersei or
never in scenes together and that's
because the actors used to date each
other many years ago and apparently they
had a very ugly breakup so now they
refuse to work together or even be in
the same room together the only way this
would work is if Cersei had Qyburn meet
with bran every time she needed him but
I think bran will stay loyal to the
Lannister brothers
I think Jaime will find Bronn before he
gets too far out of the city and Jamie's
gonna tell him that he's leaving and
he's gonna need him to help escort him
north
Jaime is taking a big risk travelling to
Winterfell and he knows this which is
why he covered up his golden hand to try
and conceal who he is if Jaime would
happen to run into some trouble on the
road he would be screwed
Jaime is no longer the swordsman he once
was and he struggles to defend himself
he will need bran to help get him safely
to Winterfell and Jamie knows bran still
once paid so he won't let him too far
out of his sight
listen to me Conti till I get what I'm
owed a dragon doesn't get to kill you
you don't get to kill you only I get to
kill you Jaime and Bronn should arrive
in Winterfell in the first episode and
I'm really hoping it plays up this way
because we could potentially see the
entire cast fighting in the Great War
and that would be incredible sir see
Qyburn the mountain and Euron won't be
there but pretty much every other
character will be helping and that's
exactly what they're gonna need to win
now there is one prediction I am
struggling with when it comes to bran I
don't know if he will survive this
series I have won back and forth on this
so many times
one day I feel like he will live and the
next day I feel like he could die I hate
to make a prediction video without
giving my definitive answer but I think
this one is 50/50 for me I could just as
easily see bran dying in battle as I
could see him getting a castle in the
end but I am 100% certain we will see
bran Jaime and Tyrion together again
there is something else I wanted to
mention when it comes to bran getting
his castle but before I go any further I
have to give a spoiler warning just in
case any of the leaks are true there was
four pages of a plot outline leaked
online and there was something in there
about bran but if you do not want to
hear any spoilers you may want to tune
out now in one of those leaked pages it
does say bran will get his castle and
apparently it will come from Tyrion it
says bran will be given the twins which
was the seed of Walder Frey now I found
this kind of interesting because this
may have been foreshadowed in season
four earlier in the video I mentioned
bran could get the twins but I wanted to
wait to talk about this until the end of
the video because of the potential
spoilers take a look at the transcript
of this leaked page it's basically a
conversation between Tyrion and bran
Tyrion knows that Jaime promised him a
castle but bran doesn't think he's going
to get it now because Jamie is dead
according to this leak but that's when
Tyrion surprise is broadened by giving
him the twins and he tells bran to
consider the Lannisters debt paid twice
over
because bran would be getting two
castles I really don't know if this is
real or not but this is very interesting
because there was a similar conversation
with tear
and brawn back in season four when
Tyrion was in the cell for Joffrey's
murder he requested to see Bronn because
at the time Tyrion was looking for
someone to be his champion against the
mountain the only problem was Bronn did
not want to fight for him because of how
dangerous it was and at the time bran
was about to get married and have his
own castle
when bran refused to fight for Tyrion he
asked broaden what he wanted and this is
what he said you once said if anyone
ever asked me to sell you out you'd
double that price the two wives you want
or two castles one of eight you do well
if you want me to kill the mountain for
you it'd be a damn big castle I'm a bit
short on costs at the moment but I can
offer you gold and gratitude cold Tyrion
asked him if he wanted two wives or two
castles so it what kind of makes sense
if Tyrion gave him the twins because
bran getting two castles could have been
foreshadowed during that scene but I
don't know if this leak is real or not
there was some other spoiler news that
came out last month that did confirm we
will see the twins again there was a
casting call for two new characters and
it was confirmed that those characters
will be Serra and sarra Frey so maybe
bran will get the twins and that's why
we are seeing the Frey daughters it's
really hard to say right now but there
is a little evidence to back up the leak
so far but not enough for me to be
convinced we might just be seeing the
phrase because Jaime and Bronn could
stop there before they go north
Jaime may try and round up whatever
troops that he can if Bronn does survive
and get a castle the twins would be a
safe bet right now but I don't see him
getting anything better than that like I
said earlier I am sure broad will find
himself in the north for a time with
Jaime and Tyrion at King's Landing he
will seek them out if he manages to
survive the wars to come I know they
will compensate him for his service
because a Lannister always pays their
debts a Lannister all gone said I'm
[ __ ] safe
but what are your predictions for bran
do you think he will assist Cersei or
will he find Jaime and Tyrion and
continue to serve one of them do you
think he will survive the series and get
his castle or will he die let me know
what you believe will happen with this
character personally I don't see him
ever working with Cersei considering
they are not allowed due to their
contracts
I think bronze character shines best
when he is what Jaime or Tyrion
especially so that's what I think he
will do but whether he lives or dies is
still at 5050 for me but leave your
questions and comments about this down
below I'm curious to see what you all
think I want to thank everyone for
stopping by to check out the video I
really do appreciate that and I also
want to thank my patreon supporters have
a great day everyone I will see you in
the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]